die ukrainische truppen die wehren sich
in diesen tagen am boden das sehen wir
immer wieder aber sie werden sich auch
weiter aus der luft hören uns liegt
dieses video hier neben mir vor
vielleicht hilft uns einmal zu verstehen
was genau sehen wir hier es ist ein
russischer konvoi und was genau wird
hier gleich getroffen werden
genau also dieses video muss man dazu
sagen hat exklusiv bekommen
einen account eclipse cura bzw crane
weapons tracker die das veröffentlicht
haben wir sehen da etwas ist schon
eingezeichnet einen konvoi der
russischen streitkräfte und ein darunter
auch ein buch luftabwehrsystem
kurz mittelstrecken luftabwehrsystem und
dieses luftabwehrsystem wir sehen es
gleich wird dann aus der luft bekämpft
dieses dieses video ist sozusagen die
aufnahme aus der drohne aus dem fall
einer türkischen markt aktive 2 tone wir
sehen uns jetzt die explosion hat dieses
luftabwehrsystem sehr effektiv bekämpft
diese bayraktar wir zwei drohnen haben
haben die türkischen staat die tierische
rüstungsindustrie auch schon verkauft
oder beziehungsweise im französischen
unterstützen einheiten eingesetzt in
syrien irgendein beziehungsweise
aserbaidschan und in libyen und haben da
auch schon mit großem erfolg russische
luftabwehrsysteme press1 bekämpft und
jetzt sind sie auch in der ukraine aktiv
also mindestens sechs stück hat 16
bayraktar tv2 hat hat die ukrainische
armee bereits bekommen es ist anzunehmen
dass da am markt weitere folgen wir
hören du sagst es ist eigentlich ein
luftabwehrsystem einmal zum verständnis
wenn ich also hier am boden eine waffe
habe die eigentlich genau gegen ziele in
der luft eingesetzt wird und dann diese
waffe aus der luft ausgeschaltet wird
was bedeutet das waren die russen nicht
schnell genug haben sie die drohnen ich
gesehen nicht mitbekommen wie kann das
passieren
also zum einen dieses spezielle dieses
buch box system ist tatsächlich eher für
größere distanzen ausgelegt diese
hätten tatsächlich beim bekämpfen müssen
wenn ich schon ein noch größerer
entfernung ist hier ist sie allerdings
hat sich schon genährt auf mehr auf
einer distanz in der sie selber
sozusagen dann wäre ihre präzisions
gelenkte munition da ins ziel
das ist allerdings kein exklusives das
problem der russischen luftabwehr dass
sie dass die drohnen das unbemannte
flugobjekt eine große herausforderung
darstellen das ist auch dann wird auch
in westlichen streitkräften über dieses
problem seit langem seit langem
nachgedacht die russischen
luftverteidigungssysteme hatten aber das
problem dass sie eben auf mehreren
konflikt werden jetzt mit dieser
türkischen drohne seit seit mehreren
jahren konfrontiert sind und da
ausgesprochen schlecht aussehen also
diese vorher ein bisschen geflickte
mythos dass die hose schön
luftabwehrsysteme zu den weltbesten
zählen würden der wurde in den letzten
jahren deutlich beschädigt und davon vor
allem durch diese bagdad bonner du du
hast es angesprochen wir die drohne
kommt ursprünglich aus der türkei ich
gehe mal einen schritt zur seite dass
wir den screen ein bisschen mehr sehen
dass hier das ist eine flagge auswertung
von vor zwei drei tagen das ist deshalb
so wichtig von vor zwei drei tagen weil
am anfang dieses krieges haben wir viele
dieser drohungen schläge gesehen und
dann war eine zeit lang ruhe so dass man
vermuten konnte das eben es doch den
russen mit der zeit gelungen ist
vielleicht mehrere dieser drohnen
abzuschießen und jetzt gab es vor ein
paar tagen also einen auffälligen flug
nämlich ein flug aus der türkei ich
markiere den mal von hier hoch in den
polnischen flughafen der bei allen
waffenlieferungen vielleicht können wir
es einmal abschminken toll bei all
diesen waffenlieferungen ganz wesentlich
ist weil sie dort hingehen und dann über
land in richtung ukraine gehen sind hier
womöglich daneben die neuen drohnen auf
diesem weg witzigerweise auch mit einer
antonov transportiert worden gern
das also mir natürlich nur darüber
spekulieren was sich in dieser fracht
befunden hat ist aber naheliegend und
wir wissen natürlich auch nicht auf
opfern diesen beitrag zugesagt dass ob
die opst den russen gelungen ist da
welche abzuschließen ob da vielleicht
welche verloren gegangen sind oder ob es
sich vielleicht möglicherweise bei
dieser lieferung auch nur um ersatzteile
handelt für irgendwelche komponenten
oder auch um also sozusagen zum beispiel
auch komponenten für die bodenstation
für die kontrollstation dieser zone
allerdings glaube ich dass tatsächlich
die türkei oder bz was war an die
ukraine daran hat an der weiteren an der
weiteren lieferung solcher und weil sie
sich bisher eben als sehr effektiv
erwiesen haben und dass ich noch nicht
bei der konvoi bekämpfung was wir immer
wieder sehen etwas besonderes uns heute
natürlich an diesem morgen und an diesem
tag ganz besonders beschäftigt ist
dieses video hier ein ukrainischer
soldat der da ein eine anti panzer waffe
auf dem rücken hat und was genau werden
ist das für eine panzer waffe ich
probier's mal zu markieren was sehen wir
hier
ich weiß nicht mal die beschriftung
erkennen kann aber dass es handelt sich
tatsächlich um ein deutsches modell das
ganze haus 3
deutschland hat ja angekündigt 1000
panzer und waffen zu liefern an die
ukraine und mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
sehen wir dann da eines dieser modelle
die dort liefert vor hast du das
standard panzerabwehrhandwaffen
der bundeswehr
mit der auf distanzen 400 500 meter
eigentliche fahrzeuge bekämpft werden
können dass
sie erfolgreich ist diese waffe auch im
vergleich zu den anderen modellen die
wir in den letzten tagen gesehen haben
die ja sehr effektiv konvois der russen
ausgeschaltet haben wo steht da die
deutsche waffe ist die eher veraltet
oder eher modern
also ich glaube das kommt immer darauf
an auf den jeweiligen einsatzbereiche
kürzere distanzen ist die durchaus
effektiv die wurde ja vorher auch schon
mal exportiert werden uns an den
konflikt im nordirak als als die
bundeswehr dann per schmerker schmerker
milizen geschult hat daneben unter
anderem auch der ganze faust 3
allerdings natürlich gelenkte
panzerabwehrhandwaffen sowie
sowie diese britische änderung oder oder
die amerikanische fbi
748 nochmal deutlich effektiver weise
höhere reichweiten haben weil sich
selbstständig gezielt suchen und
sozusagen auch es einfacher ist damit
bewegliche ziele zu bekämpfen allerdings
wird das gar nicht kleinreden das
natürlich trotzdem auf kürzerer des
gefechts distanzen durchaus eine sehr
effektive waffe hören lass uns zum
abschluss auf tierschauen und auf das
tief den frontverlauf um kiew die
ukrainische hauptstadt und diese lange
die sich da ein stück weit in den
letzten tagen schließt wenn wir das bild
einmal ins gebet nehmen dass man es
verstehen kann
diesen frontverlauf würden ich mag ihr
hier unten einmal kiew also die die
stadtgrenze und probiere uns einmal zu
schildern wo stehen die russen gerade
und von welcher seite droht momentan für
die ukrainische hauptstadt vielleicht
die größte gefahr
also die größte gefahr ist zumindest
wenn wir uns diese beiden groß verwende
anrücken die darin diese zangenbewegung
machen das sind sind 22 groß verwende
mit jeweils mehreren tausend tausenden
unterstellten soldaten
droht glaube ich noch kein direkter
einmarsch dafür sind es
mutmaßlich zu wenig einheiten die sich
da in unmittelbarer nähe kies auf alten
aber eben weiterhin diesem gestern wir
sehen dann auch denn den herrn der in
die kamera
grinst das gehört zu
der gehört zu einer einheit die direkt
dem tschetschenischen präsidenten
kadyrow auf unterstellt ist also
tschetschenische tschetschenische
mitglieder einer miliz eigentlich im
prinzip dann die dann aber ein geklärt
oder in die russische nationalgarde und
die im gegensatz zu vielen soldaten das
ist ein bisschen auffällig die
russischen streitkräfte die tatsächlich
eher demotiviert und und wenig wenig
enthusiastisch an den kampf gehen hat
man bei den aufnahmen dieser dieser
tschetschenischen kämpfer gesehen die
sind tatsächlich mit
mit einer gewissen kampfeslustiger den
niederrhein und haben sich dann halt
auch vorher gefilmt und im paradies und
sprüchen die kamera gerufen allah akbar
gerufen wie effektiv die tatsächlich
sind im kampf für das wird sich dann
noch zeigen weil in der regel
es ist natürlich so dass die in
tschetschenien wo sie gekämpft haben
abseits von den kämpfen vor 20 jahren
die in russland selbst sie eigentlich
dafür eingesetzt wurden demonstranten zu
verhaften ja im prinzip auch als sophia
prügel drucke
das sieht ein bisschen anders aus wenn
sie darauf kampferprobte kranke truppen
treffen werden allerdings dieser
vormarsch dieser beiden groß verbände
der geht langsam aber der geht um
verzeihung aber der geht langsam aber
der geht der geht voran und insofern
tatsächlich eine große gefahr dass diese
verbände irgend griffin in einer
zangenbewegung dann eingekesselt haben
wir sehen trotzdem abschluss also
mittlerweile die die front um und an
bianca im westen und auch hier im osten
ist man nicht mehr weit weg von der
stadtgrenze das muss man tatsächlich so
zusammenfassen und analysieren